the following statement is utterly
ludicrous it is also true the world's
most important advanced technology is
nearly all produced in a single
facility what's more that facility is
located in one of the most
geopolitically fraught areas on Earth an
area in which many analysts believe that
war is inevitable within the
decade the future of artificial
intelligence hangs in the
balance the Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company or
tsmc makes all of the world's most
advanced AI chips this includes nvidia's
gpus Google's tpus amd's gpus the AI
chips for Microsoft Amazon Tesla
cerebrus Sova and every other credible
competitor modern artificial
intelligence simply would not not be
possible without these highly
specialized
chips Little Wonder then that Time
Magazine recently described tsmc as
quote the world's most important company
that you've probably never heard
of Nvidia CEO Jensen hang put it more
colorfully saying quote basically there
is air and
tsmc tsmc's Chip fabrication facilities
or Fabs the buildings where chips are
physically built is located on the
western coast of Taiwan a mere 110 miles
from mainland China in this map Taiwan
is shown an orange and China is shown in
green today China and Taiwan are nearer
to the brink of War than they have been
in
decades many policy makers in Washington
predict that China will invade Taiwan
within the next 5
years a China Taiwan conflict would be
devastating for many reasons aside from
the heavy human toll one
underappreciated
consequence is that it would paralyze
the global AI
ecosystem put simply the entire field of
artificial intelligence faces an
astonishingly precarious single point of
failure in
Taiwan amid all of the fervor around AI
today this fact is not widely enough
appreciated if you are working on or are
interested in AI you need to be paying
attention
how did we get here and what can we do
about
it let's start with a brief Whirlwind
overview of the chip industry
semiconductors or chips are the most
complex object in the world that
Humanity knows how to mass produce
making semiconductors requires the
world's purest
Metals the world's most expensive
Machinery Legions of Highly specialized
engineers and atom level manufacturing
Precision it is important to distinguish
between two different types of Chip
companies first fabulous chip makers
which design but do not manufacture
their own chips and second foundaries
which manufacture chips designed by
other companies almost every well-known
chip company today is fabulous from
Nvidia to AMD to Qualcomm these
companies do not produce their own chips
instead they design chips and then they
rely on foundaries like tsmc to actually
manufacture those chips for
them there are only three companies in
the world today that are capable of
manufacturing chips anywhere near the
Leading Edge of semiconductor
technology
tsmc Samsung and Intel of those three
only one can reliably produce the
world's most advanced AI chips including
chips like nvidia's h100
gpus that one company is
tsmc as of this morning tsmc's Market
market capitalization was $470 billion
making it the 13th largest company in
the world larger than Exxon Mobile JP
Morgan Chase or
Walmart how has tsmc become such a
dominant
Force the short answer is that powerful
economies of scale exist in the world of
Chip fabrication leading inexorably to
win or take all
Dynamics making Advanced semiconductors
requires tremendous upfront and ongoing
capital expenditure in 2021 tsmc
announced that it would invest $100
billion over the next three years to
continue expanding its fabrication
capabilities no other company in the
world can justify that level of
investment tsmc can because of the sheer
volume of chips that it produces far
more than any other company in the world
a related Dynamic that helps explain
tsmc's unsalable position is what has
come to be known as the TS TMC Grand
Alliance tsmc has invested heavily over
decades to develop deep Partnerships
with dozens of companies across the
semiconductor supply chain from software
providers like Cadence to equipment
manufacturers like asml to chip
designers like
Nvidia in turn these companies have
developed their own products in
accordance with tsmc's road map leading
to powerful
lockin in summary a ation of economies
of scale Network effects and unrivaled
specialization have made tsmc
Irreplaceable and have made the entire
world deeply precariously dependent upon
it this brings us to the present
delicate geopolitical
moment last October the Biden
Administration took the dramatic step of
banning the export of all high-end AI
chips to any entity in China
the rationale Behind these measures was
clear to leverage Us control of the
global semiconductor supply chain as a
choke point to handicap China's AI
capabilities the US government is
currently formulating expansions to this
policy at the same time the US is taking
steps to reduce its Reliance on chip
fabrication facilities located in East
Asia in late 2022 tsmc announced that it
would invest $40 billion to build two
new state-of-the-art Fabs in the United
States in Arizona the first of these two
Fabs is slated to begin production in
2025 bringing Advanced chip production
to us oil will help mitigate the AI
industry's absolute dependence on Taiwan
based Fabs but the Arizona Fabs will not
solve everything their production
capacity will be modest representing
less than 5% of tsmc's total Global
output and the most advanced
semiconductor production capabilities
and technologies will remain in
Taiwan so where might things go from
here let's briefly consider a few
possibilities on this three-dimensional
chessboard let's start with the
optimistic
scenario taiwan's Central role in the
global semiconductor industry is often
referred to as its silicon Shield the
basic theory is this because China
depends so heavily on Taiwan for the
chips that it needs to keep its own
economy running China will stop short of
invading Taiwan and putting tsmc's
production at
risk and because the rest of the world
is likewise so dependent on tsmc the
United States and other powers will go
to Great Lengths to protect the island
and defend its sovereignty under this
Theory while China may continue to build
out its military and engage in Cross
straight saber rattling it will stop
short of kinetic action against
Taiwan but the Silicon she Shield is
just a theory not a
guarantee what would happen if China
were to move decisively to retake
Taiwan tsmc's Fabs would almost
certainly be rendered
inoperative it is conceivable that the
Taiwanese or even the US military would
preemptively destroy the Fabs in order
to prevent the CCP from taking control
of this valuable strategic resource even
if the physical buildings were to remain
undamaged after a Chinese invasion it is
unrealistic that the CCP would be able
to continue operating the Fabs to
produce Cutting Edge chips keeping
Leading Edge Fabs running requires
ongoing deep partnership with
organizations across the global
semiconductor ecosystem as well as a
steady inflow of materials equipment and
services these would be denied to an
invading
power let me say this one more time if
or when China invades Taiwan tsmc's Fabs
will in all likelihood go
offline this will mean that no more
Nvidia h100s or any other cutting EDI
chips will be able to be produced
anywhere in the
world what would this mean for the world
of
AI after tsmc the company best position
to step up and produce cuttingedge AI
chips is
Samsung Samsung is currently the only
company in the world other than tsmc
that is capable of producing 3 nanometer
chips today's cuttingedge
technology but Samsung's production
capabilities are far inferior to tsmc's
today in a best case scenario it would
take Samsung years to scale up to tsmc's
current AI chip yields and
volumes this brings us to America's
former chip Champion
Intel it was hardly a decade ago that
Intel's chip manufacturing capabilities
were the Envy of the world but in recent
years Intel has fallen behind
the company struggled mightily in its
transition to both 10 nanometer and 7
nanometer node Technologies even
resorting to Outsourcing some of its
Leading Edge production to
tsmc under CEO Pat Ginger Intel aspires
to regain its chipm Supremacy with an
ambitious plan to Leap Frog tsmc and
begin producing 2 nanometer chips in
2024 whether this ambitious plan will
actually prove achievable however
remains to be seen
before we despair too much let us note a
couple encouraging
points first keep in mind that a
considerable stock of AI chips already
exists in the world and even in a worst
case scenario these chips would remain
in
use second while the most advanced AI
chips like Google's tpus or nvidia's
h100s can only be manufactured in Taiwan
there are many Fabs around the world
from the US to Europe to Israel that are
cap capable of producing lagging Edge
logic chips at
scale though they are far less powerful
than today's leading AI chips these
previous generation chips could be used
in a pinch to support some AI Computing
workloads ultimately though it would be
devastating for Humanity to lose its
ability to produce the chips that power
today's Cutting Edge artificial
intelligence progress in AI would be
profoundly
disrupted let us hope the diplomacy
prevents
s